they need to have this in the Olympics I
would bring home gold high five me today
re nuria's we're gonna put blindfolds on
a face and put Oreos in her mouth I love
an Oreo Oreos are not sacred you know
it's a starting brown we can play let's
have some fun I'm interested that we're
gonna be blindfolded because because
that's gonna change the perception if I
see an image of a birthday cake I have a
birthday cake oreo my mind's already
going birthday cake and it tastes like a
birthday cake I don't see a birthday
cake oh maybe it tastes like a radish
all right can't see a damn thing
oh that's a little sour it's like oh so
sour lemon yeah I think you're right I
know what it is it's key lime pie is it
key lime pie
what why about having a favor Cheers
no mmm no try it it's like a breakfast
is a pop tart this tastes like a pop
tart filling in silent Oreo yes hold on
I just taste something in some kind of
pie now it's blueberry it's blueberry
muffin Oh what is that an option I don't
know it's strawberry bad dark flavored
we know that's blueberry blueberry pie
oh yes wow you're good blueberry pie
blueberry Pop Tart flavored
I'm not a fan of this one mm-hmm
cocoa puffs or disses at cocoa puffs
this is the og Oreo I got him
hold on that's too easy it's just
chocolate chocolate this is an Oreo I
believe chocolate final antics
yeah the what I'm very shocked
something very fruity it smells like a
cherry I see this one smells insane
maybe even like a twizzler or Red Vine
that's the consistency of toothpaste but
this isn't twizzler I'll pay you $100
you heard that Internet oh my god you
know what it is you know it is wait I
think I know what it is that smells like
a goddamn swedish fish ID up dude I
think it's swedish fish Wow all right
is it swedish fish oh my god close that
wasn't oh yeah you're real Zeiger you're
about to get a hundred big ones I knew
it
I wasn't too mad at the blueberry the
Blue Room is interesting the original
you know I'm not in a sequels you'd have
to have a pretty damn good sequel to
trump the first yeah we needed I got
Back to the Future Part 2 exactly Sister
Act to Dark Knight it's easy to be
weirded out by the other flavors but I
think they're pretty yummy their first
we're young